you're talking about hans how much have
you players notice the interviews that
hans have given and his
frustrations in his tournaments yeah i
think the frustrations are mainly mine
because i'm not able to crush the
tournament i'm also not able to crash
the interviews so i'm like you know i
don't have a field where i can dominate
anymore so that's difficult uh but it's
been very entertaining and
the interesting thing about hans is that
he's definitely acting sometimes you can
see he's about to crack into
into laughter as he speaks himself but
at the same time if you look at his
games there is really emotion like he is
really emotionally affected as well
because he's uh taking some rash
decisions sometimes he tills so uh it's
quite interesting you know the
combination between acting and uh
genuine emotion and that's i think what
many streamers also go through that's
quite fascinating you know that there is
like a borderline somewhere there's your
personality and then there is the
exaggeration but somewhere there is
it waves in together